[Music]
along with a crime drama from the
heaviest of Hollywood heavyweights we've
got a musical comedy based off an Off
Broadway show season 3 of a prime sci-fi
comedy a dramedy about an Iranian
American and her family plus an unheard
of seventh season of a Netflix original
series it's all coming up on this week's
what to watch money flows freely here
now I do love that money
sir hitting theaters is the Western
crime drama killers of the flower moon
this film was directed by Martin scorsi
and stars Leonardo Dicaprio and Robert
dairo not to mention people like Jesse
plens John Lithgow and Brendan Fraser in
supporting roles and all of that stuff
wrapped up in a nice little movie is
reason number one to check this one out
reason two is that it's based on a
popular 2017 non-fiction book of the
same name by David Gran and tells the
story of a series of murders in the
Osage Nation of Oklahoma in the 1920s
after oil was found on tribal land and
reason three because it premiered at
cans back in May killers of the flower
moon is already certified fresh at 95%
on the Tomato Meter and is generating
plenty of Oscar buzz to go with it good
luck against barbin Heimer if mom and
dad got married again then we'd have a
real family what if we trick them into
getting back
together what are you doing here the
twins singing its way into theaters is
the comedy film dicks the musical this
one is based on an off Bradway musical
with a not sayfe for work title
identical twins if you insist I say it
and comes from director Larry Charles if
his name sounds familiar it's because he
was a writer on Seinfeld and he directed
a bunch of Sasha Baron Cohen
mockumentaries like Borat pretty solid
reason and I have to check this one out
another would be the Stellar cast with
Megan malali Nathan Lane Megan the
stallion and Bowen Yang among others in
this story about two business
adversaries who realize their identical
twins and switch places to reunite their
divorced parents in other words it's
basically The Parent Trap with a very
adult twist plus this is the first
musical film from the studio a24 which
just keeps giving us Banger after Banger
it seems and after premiering at the
Toronto Film Festival it's sitting fresh
at 77% on the Tomato Meter with about 60
reviews and Counting no no no he's
nowhere in the system so I rebooted him
from a backup
copy there is another you living in Lake
View do you think this is identity theft
processing and checking the startup disc
for season 3 is the c comedy series
upload starring Robbie Amel and Andy
Aloe this Prime show is set in a
technologically advanced future where
humans can choose to be uploaded into a
virtual afterlife it's a very
interesting premise and a great reason
to give this one a try it was created by
Greg Daniels whose resume printed or
digitally uploaded includes adapting the
office for the US co-creating parks and
wreck and writing for SNL and The
Simpsons okay we get it and you get
another reason to download upload lastly
the first two seasons are fresh on the
Tomato Meter with critics PR raing it
for witty writing and a Winsome cast
that makes it an afterlife worth living
and speaking of cast Janine Mason has
joined for season 3 as a senior exec at
the uploading company Horizon in charge
of new products and cyber security ooh
she sounds important this is my family
in a nutshell the Disco King the
Troublemaker JFK Jr minus the plane
crash The Brainiac The Goth the hippie
the Greaser and the metrosexual and me
oh my God I love Jack Queens oh no I'm
I'm an actor getting a limited
theatrical release this week is the
Persian version this dramedy follows the
ups and downs of a young Iranian
American woman played by Leila mamed who
clashes with her mother and learns a big
family secret while her father recovers
from a heart transplant intrigued yes
that's reason number one to see this
another reason is that it was directed
by Miriam kesars known for her 2011
certified fresh film circumstance which
won the audience award at Sundance just
like the Persian version did earlier
this year love that consistency and
speaking of which after the festival
circuit the movie is fresh at 87% on the
Tomato Meter with about 30 reviews and
Counting that's reason three to head to
theaters for this one and reason 3A is
that it's just good to get out sometimes
I am locked the in it's second period
can we stop with a screaming Alex Jones
sit down I mean that's the whole show
that's what we're doing please do not
break the fourth wall we just had it
repaired and finally returning for a
seventh season on Netflix is the adult
animated sitcom big mouth and if you
feel like it's too late to hop into a
show after seven seasons you're dead
wrong because this one has been renewed
for an eighth and final season making it
Netflix's longest running original
scripted series ever which gives you
plenty of time to get caught up before
the end it's perfect planning and you're
welcome another reason to consider big
mouth is the relatable Coming of Age
premise and storylines focusing on a
group of students at an awkward time AKA
puberty as they form relationships and
learn tough lessons along the way and
thirdly along with the usual voice cast
that includes co-creator Nick koll John
meany Maya Rudolph and AO Dey the
confirmed list of guest stars for season
7 is too long to list but it does
feature Megan the stallion Lupita nongo
zazzy beat Rosie Perez Zack galanakis
and more hey it's a big math to fill get
it Big M
okay well there you have it five picks
to keep your eyes focused on something
besides your phone for a while be sure
to let us and your fellow viewers know
in the comments what you did check out
whether it was on this list or not
remember to check out rot tomatoes.com
for the latest updates on score and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large
that's all for today fresh family until
next week stay
fresh